let's uh check out the mailbag you can
email info at davidpakman.com if you
have any questions comments concerns
trolling that you want to do info
davidpakman.com is the place let's uh
jump right into it vera from finland
says pro-lifers next move very exciting
hey david i for one am excited for the
next step for the pro-life movement and
i have a proposal make organ donation
mandatory after all lots of people die
every year because they don't get an
organ transplant that they need so what
is more pro-life than preventing those
deaths honestly i think this should have
been their first step since it's much
less radical than forcing people to give
birth corpses don't need organs after
all and i'm sure an all-powerful god can
just give you new ones if the afterlife
exists so chop chop pro-lifers your work
is not done
unless of course i'm misunderstanding
the movement says vera and it's not
actually about preserving life at all
but that would mean they're lying
douchebags and lying as a sin so i'm
sure that can't be it yet this is a good
this is a good point and the email is
tongue-in-cheek but we've talked about
this before in the context of
there aren't even things we force people
to do in death
so how is it we can force them to do it
medically
in life that's a contrast that seems
like a
jarring double standard and vera
correctly points it out and the other
double standard is if they can't claim
to care about children
then they should be funding
uh pre-k
head start paid paternity leave paid
maternity leave all of these different
things increasing and making permanent
the child tax credits the larger all of
these things and they don't
why because it's not really about that
it never was
and uh in unfortunately in reality their
next move isn't going to be to properly
fund maternal care their next move isn't
going to be to make organ donation
mandatory which would save many many
many lives uh it's going to be to try to
either outright ban abortion at the
federal level or undo gay marriage or
something else that will be horrible
those will be their next steps and we
know it because they told us that that
would be it next email is from john john
wrote in about the shooting in japan and
says hey david first time sending in a
question love the show here's the
question could the latest shooting in
japan potentially be stimulated by the
united states or is it only coincidence
that this would happen in the midst of
heavy gun controversy i don't know what
the shooter's reason was but i'm
thinking more motivation to action could
we see more shootings in places mostly
considered safe due to the us's
irresponsible actions towards gun
control which is inherently giving more
mass shooting examples as we know japan
gun violence is very rare so perhaps as
we see more shootings here it may
inspire shooters elsewhere lastly if
this were to happen could there
potentially be some point a third party
to interfere and tell us to get our guns
in check for example criticism in the
u.n would love your take thanks john so
the second part i don't know about
the question about the influence is a
good one now john isn't saying and i'm
not interpreting this to mean
is it possible someone in the u.s is
actually to blame for the shooting of
former japanese prime minister shinzo
abe no the answer to that would be no
but the question of
has american gun culture
which has legitimized and mainstreamed
using firearms to solve problems
disagreements conflicts
could that be sort of leaking over
into other countries and the answer is
sure it could
sure it could i mean the united states
has a very
uh hegemonic culture in many ways um and
that includes media of course uh
tv shows movies etc
to some degree also in literature and
books
uh so why couldn't it also be that hey
look in the united states there's this
you have a problem you have some
disagreement you go and you get a gun
and you and you solve it so it as a
theoretical question i think the answer
is absolutely yes there were questions
as to whether the motivations and the
particular assassination of abe were
even political and i believe the shooter
said that they're not
but at least as a theoretical question
completely valid uh completely plausible
langdon wrote in about right wingers who
troll me and langdon says hi david i've
been following you for quite some time
now on social media i joined rumble and
troth essential about three to four
months ago i've noticed 90 or maybe more
of the comments or replies you get are
from right wing trollers i would love to
get your opinion as to why my personal
opinion is these people are so insecure
they feel the need to defend their right
wing beliefs when anyone challenges them
thank you i actually don't think that's
what it is i think it's much simpler the
reason that ninety percent or more of
the replies to my posts on rumble and
truth social aka truth central are
attacks and trolling is that those
platforms are overwhelmingly
right-wingers their right-wing platforms
rumble less so and rumble seems to more
proactively want to have more diverse
content whereas truth sensual or truth
social or whatever you want to call it
is more overtly right-wing
um the users are just on the right and
so they see my content and they troll me
and they attack me i think it's that
simple quite frankly langdon
david wrote in about cassie hutchinson
if hutchinson was so bad
why was she allowed to work for steve
scalise ted cruz
and to be the chief staff assistant to
mark meadows wouldn't she have been
weeded out before january 6th how does
she support herself now i don't know how
she supports herself now but this is an
endless question
trump ran on i will hire the best people
i might not have experience in foreign
policy or trade or whatever although he
claimed he was a genius in those areas
as well but his big thing was i will
hire the best people i hired the best
people to build my buildings and i'm
gonna hire the best people that will be
my strength and then he hired all of
these different people who then quit or
he fired them and he said they were
terrible which of course calls into
question his bona fides as someone who
can hire the right people i'm talking
about
you know william barr and rex tillerson
and um
john bolton all these people who as he
has since attacked well it sounds like
you weren't really that great at hiring
people and of course the same thing
applies to cassidy hutchinson's
testimony they insist now
disgruntled
not a very good employee not
particularly smart didn't really have
access to any of the things she claims
she can't be trusted terrible terrible
terrible well she was not only hired but
promoted brought to the west wing to
have a very
uh
close level of access to mark meadows
and sometimes donald trump
why if she was so horrible and
incompetent well because they're lying
because they're lying that's what they
say about everybody once they've fallen
out of their good graces
grant wrote in grant says looking for
your advice hey david my conservative
friends often bring up talking points
they don't fully understand but they're
convinced they have everything right
sounds like many people i know i
politely inform them when they're
incorrect but unfortunately i don't have
much skill at formulating arguments or
remembering facts when i refute their
claims but don't have the hard evidence
to immediately back it up they assume
i'm disagreeing just based on my
personal feelings
i'll be honest i don't have the deepest
understanding of government the economy
etc i never took any political economic
or history courses in college i'd like
to think i have a fair amount of common
sense and i'm an adequately logical
thinker but it's often not enough i'm
not a fan of confrontation i sometimes
crumple under the pressure when
dialoguing how can i better prepare for
these discussions okay so here's the
best thing you can do graham this
doesn't just apply to you
it is impossible to always be prepared
with the facts
on every issue it's it's just not
possible this happens to me as well the
most important thing you can do
is understand how people are thinking or
not thinking when they make these claims
and be prepared to probe how they came
to these conclusions
i don't know that much about
i don't know what's an example i don't
know that much about
uh
so many different things i don't know
that much about the ford versus chevy
debate right that's a debate i don't i
could not care less about it i remember
in high school there were the more uh
there was a contingent of kids in my
high school who were very big on ford
versus chevy and certainly american cars
are better than foreign cars okay i
didn't know a lot about it but my
instinct was that these were not
conclusions they were coming to from a
very evidence-based perspective so
without knowing a lot about the issue
there would be
very easy ways for me to say okay so
chevy's the good one ford's bad okay how
did you come to that conclusion well uh
i had a chevy and it lasted a really
long time oh okay that's interesting and
how many chevys are out there well i
don't know
is it possible that it's millions yeah
it's possible so the fact that you had a
chevy
and it lasted a long time does that tell
us a lot about all chevys well you know
yeah i feel like okay so you get the
point the the point is
understand and learn the socratic method
of questioning and how to probe people's
beliefs
and you don't have to be nor is it
possible to be as prepared as you might
want on every issue
understand how to get people to realize
for themselves
that they may believe things not based
on good evidence
mice wrote in about a texting scam and
says i wrote a comment on youtube to
your story on liz cheney and i got a
reply saying send me a text with your
picture and a phone number is this real
it is not real so let me
we are playing a whack-a-mole with
scammers on all platforms instagram
youtube facebook everywhere
on youtube right now there are tons of
people who are using my face as their
profile picture and they're responding
to people and saying hey contact me via
whatsapp i'll send you money i'll send
you free crypto i'll send you a free
product if you review or whatever okay
i'm not texting anybody i can't even
respond to emails that i get i'm just
too busy so i'm not texting with anybody
in the audience number one
number two i'm not using whatsapp to
contact anybody
and number three
i'm not sending money to people in the
audience
if we did any kind of giveaway
i would talk about it on the show and
you would know it i'm not gonna be
silent on the show about a giveaway and
then reply to youtube comments one on
one okay so i'm not texting anybody i'm
not what zapping anybody don't fall for
report those accounts we're reporting
them as quickly as we can and uh
that's it i'm not don't don't respond to
any of it these are scams sean wrote in
about trump's presidential announcement
isn't it obvious right sean that trump
is announcing an early run because he
knows he's going to be indicted this
then gives him a loud speaker to claim
he's being arrested and charged because
of politics he will claim to be a
political prisoner i actually don't
think so i think trump has actually been
delaying announcing the presidential run
in order to not have the
reporting requirements for money that
comes in for as long as possible i i do
think there's a very good chance trump
announces a run and it'll probably be
i don't know maybe right before but
probably right after the midterms but i
don't think that the strategy is
announced really soon to try to mitigate
or in somehow influence
the potentially forthcoming indictments
i just don't think so if people disagree
with me just let me know and lastly
another perspective on trump's run uh
alan says sir i keep seeing trump might
announce a 2024 presidential run soon is
this something we should be hoping for
there's potential to split and ruin the
republican party for at least the next
couple of election cycles so there's two
sides to this
um one that we've discussed is
what does it do for republicans for
trump to run
the other one we've discussed is was it
what does it do for trump for a lot of
republicans to run
i think that a lot of republicans
running
helps trump in the sense that if you get
all these two and three percent type
people maybe nikki haley maybe ted cruz
or whoever that splits the more
mainstream republican electorate for a
while while trump just consolidates
support so that's more or less what
happened in 2016. i think more
candidates is good for trump
trump running i can't tell you whether
it's good or bad for the republican
party i think if trump runs and loses to
desantis for example it's bad for the
republican party it will fracture it and
that would be a really great thing but
some of this we won't know until we see
how do the midterms go number one
and what level of approval does donald
trump have among the republican
electorate questions we we won't know
in the 2024 context until after the
november midterms but we'll of course be
talking about it and covering it we have
a fantastic bonus show for you today
sign up at joinpakman.com coupon code
big voting22 we will see you then or
i'll see you back here on monday